hello everyone and welcome to a most
interesting game from yesterday's banter
blitz Cup it's Ali Reza's future versus
German Grandmaster Georg Meyer and like
I said it's quite an interesting game
for a few reasons which I will mention
during the game but without further ado
let's let's just check it out so ali
reza opens with c-4 with the English
opening and Margot's for b6 he wants the
early finger to the light square bishop
will Knight to c3 Bishop to b7 Knight to
f3 and Knight to f6 so just nice rapid
development we have g3 preparing to fee
and get to the lights work bishop and
now we reach a position where black has
a variety of options you can go c5 you
can go d5 you can go a 5 you can go easy
d6 well really a lot of options here but
Bishop characters on f3 is a move you
don't usually see here and this is what
Meyer goes for and it does mess up
White's pawn structure early on however
he gives up the bishop pair also very
early on for a classical game this would
be this would be a big no but for a
three-minute blitz game he gives it a
try so let's see how future deals with
this surprise he plays each captures on
f3
we have c5 by black a grabbing hold of
the d4 square but white pushes d4 either
way you have to play it if characters
then you get a nice early Queen into the
game but first night the c6 putting more
pressure and inviting fallujah to go for
d5 to grab more space in the center and
it's already has of move 6 that we have
a completely new game so a very
interesting stuff so future does that he
goes for d5 we have Knight to d4 and
again a very exciting moment fuchsia
doesn't go for Bishop g2 and castles
rather he goes for Bishop to h3 he
doesn't want to let this night well
leave the d4 square alive so to say he
wants to play Bishop to e3 capture
character and win a pawn this way he
doesn't want to allow the knight to
escape via DF v square so Marc continues
with g6 he wants to develop also pin get
to the dark square Bishop we have
castles Bishop to g7 and now Bishop to
e3 saying next move I'm gonna capture
your knight and win a pawn here and
there is not much black can do about it
for example in the game nights the h5
was played but you don't really have a
way of way of dealing with this so nice
to h5 now the bishop guards at Fallujah
are not interested in creating some more
King side weaknesses by playing g4 and
then capturing first he plays Bishop to
g4 he prepares it and now he says okay
I'm either gonna mess up your bone
structure in front of the King or you go
back and I win upon so here ecigs is
probably best to allow maybe maybe
captures and then you can play Queen c7
maybe Castle queenside and played that
kind of a game but instead Meyer goes
back and he says okay you grab my pawn
and I'm just gonna play it being down
upon so the ship captures pawn captures
and Queen captures and like that fiducia
is up upon where black still has no good
discoveries because of just Queen
captures and g7 so we have castles here
and now just push it back to h3 still
there are no useful discoveries here so
nothing to worry about we loop the c8
both players continue development
rook a to c1 and now II 6 challenging
the center but also creating the threat
of Knight captures as now the pawn also
guards the d5 square so this would be a
useful discovery so future goes back we
have Queen to d3 and now we have a trade
in the center captures captures in the
now a 5-mile grabs more space on the
Queen side and future goes the Knights
to b5 he offers a rook trade he wants to
play d6 and night to c7 black cannot go
d6 just yet as the rook would hang so
here
Margot's for rook to c5 he puts more
pressure on the d5 pawn here and
basically forces a trade on c5 with
captures captures and now he would like
to play the six but of course fallujah
doesn't allow it he pushes d6 himself we
have looked yet getting the rook into
the game and now Knight to c7 and
excellent square for the knight kicking
the rook back and also preparing Queen
b5 which will now count with an attack
on both of these pawns here so look the
e5 defending one of the points but now
first f4 you kick the rook away
we have rook to e4 and now Queen the b5
with threats of capturing both pawns so
there's nothing
be done about that but you can grab some
material yourself so rook to b4 and now
comes Queen captures on c5 with rook
actress and B to end rook to e1 getting
the final rook into the game and now you
could grab the pawn here but you might
be worried a little about some back rank
issues if the knight moves you can't
really start developing your pieces so
here h5 first Meier makes an escape
route for his King but now it's Fallujah
they've grabbed the pawn queen captures
an a5 and now it's future who is up two
points not one and here Ammar goes for
Queen to b8 he wants to go rook to be
one trade of the rooks and he says okay
with with a lot of lights worse whole
lights were wholesaler here in front of
your King I will maybe bring my knife to
e4 or g4 maybe I can bring my queen all
the way down and then maybe I can hold
this even though I'm down two pawns
however he misses a tactic here so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
it this very elusive tactic while I'll
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting that it's
actually the night that's preventing the
rookie eight moves so what do you do you
overload the knight so congratulations
to everyone who found it and for those
who just want to enjoy the show it's
Bishop captures undies and undies seven
now of course if Knight captures you no
longer have control of the 8th route p8
wins the Queen so after Bishop captures
and d7 Bishop the f8 was played saying
okay no problem next I'm gonna capture
your your pawn here but now this
actually is a threat because this will
not come with check so fallujah finds
Bishop the c6 now again he gives up the
d6 pawn but he finds Knight the IE 8
which is again very dangerous as the
Bishop covers this so you cannot trade
if you trade again you just lose your
queen here with check so Knight to g4
not with the threat of captures and f2
so it's already getting very dangerous
for white as well and here future can
actually solve all of his problems by
captures captures in Queen c3 it's
sufficient to win the game as you are
now threatening to win the rook but also
you're threatening to checkmate the King
as the Queen also covers this diagonal
so
if you go for some like this is just a
nice made here as you can see so what
you would have to do after this idea of
an IG for if you went for this captors
captors in Quincy 3 you would force
black to go back but then you go back
herself and then slowly but surely da
pond will have a final say in the matter
so after Knight to g4 this would have
been a good plan for future but he
decides to go for Queen to c3 right away
and now comes Queen to b4 Meier offers a
queen trade but he misses a very
interesting tactic so feel free to pause
the video I'm just kidding you of course
you all see what's happening here back
here if you lose your plate Queen to g7
and it was made in one so very very
exciting game and a very interesting
finish to the game they both had some 15
to 20 seconds on the clock I believe so
it wasn't that severe especially if
you're if you're you know a bullet
player here and there but anyone can
miss a mate in one so this is what
happened and I really enjoyed especially
the the early night Bishop captures an
f3 that was a very exciting as I really
was interested to see how he will deal
with this and really if you were just
showed that you should you should never
play this even in a three minute blitz
game and also the bishop character son
b7 tactic was which was quite nice so
first that then this and also finishing
the game with Queen to g7 mate that's
that that was a that was a nice touch so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
the match finished with eight and a half
to one and a half in ferocious favor if
you want to check out the entire match I
will put a link in the description below
so you can check it out on just 24s
website you can even see if you lose
just stream and comment on all of the
games from the match if you're
interested in that and this like I said
this these were the quarterfinals would
no sorry yeah these were the
quarterfinals original advances to the
semi-finals and there he will face an
iron on and the cross and in the
semi-finals phases son and figure of his
old nemesis and then well if all if all
goes well for future he should meet he
will meet either Carson or or sugar of
in the finals of the
enter blitz cup so that's it that's it
for the game a lot of you have been
asking me why are you not receiving
notifications from YouTube when I upload
a video I already mentioned this a few
months back but it's because YouTube's
resources are well they're overloaded
and not everyone can receive a
notification you know in the in the
exact moment that I upload the video so
for example maybe when I uploaded maybe
10,000 people will receive it right away
then maybe 10,000 in another hour I
don't know how the algorithm works but
it's it goes you know a little by little
not everyone can receive it right away
but if you if you were one of those
people that really want to see the video
as soon as it's uploaded you're welcome
to follow me on Instagram where I will
we're where I will mention that I've
uploaded a video using the Instagram
story so that's pretty much
instantaneous so if you're using
Instagram you're welcome to check it out
I will just post some random photo of
either meadow or myself and I will just
write a new video is out to go watch so
that way you can know that it's that
it's out there
and the link the link to the Instagram
profile will also be the first thing you
see in the description below so there
you have it I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Federico pontine
Alberto utter Raj Vina and Chris Hershey
and a whole hair Romero Romero for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the morphe saga checking up
on you wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an external race today